okay now some economic theories reject
the idea that debt is always a problem
modern monetary theory for example tell
me why you're right and if there's any
middle ground here and for those who
don't know modern monetary theory claims
the government like the u.s can spend
more freely so long as it borrows in its
own currency as new york magazine put it
the u.s can't run out of dollars because
it can print them so tell me why you're
right and if there's any middle ground
between you and the mmts
it's so totally correct that the united
states can't run out of dollars because
they print them but again
what mmt doesn't deal with
is the fact that one man's debts are
another man's assets
and so
what happens is throughout history this
has always happened
that if you print it and you have lower
buying power
you don't want to hold your wealth in
that if you think about like people
think that their money is safe if it's
in cash
but last year they lost over seven
percent in buying power and they're
losing buying power at a very fast rate
and as they wake up to that and they are
now waking up to that then they sell
that debt and what that means
mechanistically
is the central bank then either comes in
and prints more money because they have
to make up for those people who are
leaving which creates more inflation or
they don't print the money and when they
don't print the money then you have a
debt crisis so that's where we are in
the cycle that's the mechanics of it
it's been the mechanics throughout
history i wish it was true i wish mmt
was true which means okay actually you
can print and borrow all that that you
want and there are no problems with it
but i mean come on right right okay but
you think there's no middle ground you
cannot do there's no i'm just dealing
with the supply demand the mechanics
literally like do you want to hold your
money do you want to hold your money in
cash now
i mean like you decide what you want to
do you can do that but it would be it
seems pretty crazy to me and that's
where we're making a shift right now
there's a very big paradigm shift that's
going on in which there's a state where
you came from not worrying about
inflation these paradigm shifts last
about 10 years and the way they work is
there's a certain mentality that
everybody believes and that new paradigm
is we don't worry about inflation we
have new technologies um and so on and
everybody wants to be in the new tech
stocks because they're going to be the
revolution but they don't pay much
attention to the price and that the
central bank produces a lot of money so
you produce a lot of liquidity and that
process starts to have one extreme
confidence in one thing then there's the
wake-up call then there's the adjustment
to the wake-up call in other words now
people are thinking well maybe i
shouldn't keep my money in cash and they
also start to think about inflation so
people when they enter into a labor
contracts they want more protections for
inflation or they are buying assets to
protect themselves against inflation
which contributes more to inflation and
when that happens then the central bank
has to do what the central bank is doing
it tightens monetary policy so you lose
money to inflation and your interest
bill goes up and that creates a squeeze
that becomes intolerable and that's the
way the system has always worked